hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our
daily live stream uh this is a way we've
started this a couple of
weeks actually months ago now as a way
for all of us to stay connected during
times of social distancing and school
closures and it's a
time to just have an interesting
conversation we have a lot of
interesting guests
and today we will just be doing an ask
me anything
where you can literally ask me anything
for those of y'all on youtube or
facebook
start putting your questions in i have
team members who are helping me out uh
surfacing questions to answer and i'm
literally happy to answer
anything uh before we start i want to
give a special thanks to several
corporate partners who
have allowed us to do what we're doing
especially with our response to covet 19
especially thanks to bank for america
google.org hd fastly and
artist we were running a deficit even
before this crisis and you can imagine
our
server costs have gone up dramatically
we're trying to accelerate a whole
series of programs
and so this support has helped a lot and
special thanks to the many other
foundations and corporations that have
helped us
uh well beyond before kovid but i do
like to emphasize that we are still
running a deficit so if you're in a
position to do so
uh please think about making a donation
to khan academy every donation
makes a difference so with that uh let's
just jump into
uh asking me anything for whatever
that's worth
it looks like there's already some
questions that have come in
so uh jason dunlap from facebook asked
hey mr khan member of khan academy since
2011. so jason you've been with us
since near the beginning is there a
particular subject matter with which you
struggled
how did you deal with it um
i think the first time that i really
found myself
struggling with a class you know i was
a student that was that tended to do
really
you know i i was academically doing fine
most of my
career but then once i got into high
school i got really
i wanted to accelerate even more i got
very i guess you could say
mathematically ambitious
and i think i was my sophomore year i
went to the local university
and i started taking classes there and
the first few classes i
i found quite straight you know they
didn't cause too much trouble but i
remember when i took that first real
analysis course
for those of you all who aren't familiar
with real analysis that's kind of the
first
real like mathematically math course
where you go really deep into proofs you
go really deep into
the analysis of you know the real number
system and functions and all of that
and i think that switching gears from
what you typically do
in most of your math your high school
career
of where you're learning about for sure
a lot of concepts and procedures but
you're not
as mathematically rigorous uh as
i guess you could say real
mathematicians are that actually did
cause a little bit of like you know i
remember there's a couple of weeks where
i just like
you know of course a leads to b uh why
do i have to prove it
uh but then once i got over it i i
definitely started really enjoying it
and you know that's part of the reason
why
i eventually became a math major because
i thought the beauty and that kind of
real
formal formal logic but that was
definitely
a time that i at least you know for for
a period
uh struggled a bit uh there's let's see
if there's
other courses that i that i
that i really had difficult you know as
as i went
you know in my khan academy mode part of
the fun of my job
uh is being able to refresh or learn new
subjects
to be able to teach it better and you
know organic chemistry is interesting
because
i did take it in college and when i took
it in college i i learned it i did fine
in the course
but when we were going to cover it on
khan academy i really wanted to be able
to do it in a way
that was as intuitive as what we could
do in math or physics or regular
chemistry or any other subject
and it did take me a little bit of time
to get that intuition
for organic chemistry because the way
it's typically taught
the way it's typically surfaced in
textbooks it just feels like a bunch of
random mechanisms that you
that a lot of students just go through
and memorize but
when you really start to think about it
there are some very beautiful
themes or concepts that transcend all of
organic chemistry
it's all about electronegativity which
which atom in a molecule is the one that
really wants to hog those electrons
really really wants
those electrons closer to it and from
then you could that you actually can
deduce
a lot of the mechanisms you don't have
to memorize them all
or even if you do memorize some of them
you can kind of
see the intuition of why the universe
does what it does uh because of the
electronegativity but that was
definitely
a little bit of it took me a little bit
of time to start to see that
thread line um there's other things you
know there's there's definitely
parts of biology where i'm like well why
does that lead to that and i would start
calling up friends and
people who are professors in the subject
and they would say oh well actually
that's an open area of research and so i
often times said well why don't they
just tell everyone in the textbook that
we don't know
that that's an area of research because
i actually think that is more satisfying
to know that
okay no one actually has the intuition
for exactly why that leads to that
and by the way if you're asking the
question you're already at the frontiers
of research which i think is
a pretty cool idea uh but yeah let's see
facebook miguel hernandez asked what is
your biggest challenge now
as the leader of khan academy um
great question miguel i i think there's
a lot of layers to that
i think you know my
i would say the overarching question
that sometimes keeps me up at night is
you know it's it's if i were if khan
academy from 10 years ago saw khan
academy today
sal from 10 years ago saw khan academy
today
he was said wow that thing that started
in in this walk-in closet
got much bigger than expected to see
that we're over 200
folks employees around the world we have
translation projects we're across
subjects of grades
that sal from 10 years ago would have
been overjoyed we're like wow khan
academy
has kind of had escape velocity it's
able to have the impact that it was
you know just a delusion just a dream 10
years ago
but i think now you know i feel like i
guess you could say a stress or an
urgency
that we don't squander the opportunity
that we have it's great that khan
academy
has 100 million registered users and it
serves tens of millions every month
but there's billions of people who need
to be empowered
and you know not just on a superficial
level but you know we want to be able to
empower them deeply
across subjects and grades and create
ways for them to plug into the broader
system
and there's just still a lot of work to
do you know even with this coveted
crisis
there's a lot that's negative about this
crisis the silver lining is that there's
an open-mindedness
to thinking about all things but
especially education in new ways and so
i
i sometimes you know there's there's a
tension between
this is a marathon at the end of the day
like you know the world isn't going to
change overnight
but there's moments where there's
openness to new solutions and i'm always
thinking like well how can we
khan academy really serve people right
now right when the
need is urgent so i think that's kind of
the high level the biggest
tension is how do you balance between
moving fast and being scrappy and ultra
entrepreneurial with
there's a lot of um you know khan
academy has a lot of users now you have
to bring them along
we have a large team we got to make sure
that we're aligned that we're all kind
of
marching in the same direction so that
so that we can
use the resources that folks are
donating to us as well as possible
i think one double click below that it's
making sure that we have the resources
to do what work we want to do and that
and that we can treat it as a marathon
uh that we do have visibility over not
just this year or the next several years
but we have the visibility to be able to
plan
and actually create what the world needs
and not just follow
you know the latest trend or whatever
seems to be hot at that moment
i think that's another uh thing that i
think a lot about and then you double
click
below that and that gets a little bit
more to the tactical level at khan
academy
and this is you know every year and
every few months we have
spirited conversations about
prioritizing and that's hard because
when you have a limited amount of
resources
and you think about the scope of what
khan academy is trying to do
uh there's things that you know we're
able to do
and improve on every year and then
there's things that are super valuable
that we just don't have the resources we
just don't have the capacity to do every
year
and that's always a little bit
heartbreaking and that's always hard to
um to kind of thread the needle uh on on
on that level uh but when you really
think about all of the dimensions of
konica i mean i have to remind myself
sometimes too because i'm sometimes the
mindset oh yeah it was the thing we have
the software
but if you think about you know we're
trying to cover you know 13 or 14 years
grade levels we have khan academy kids
we're covering now not just math but
we're we're doing uh
english and language arts reading social
emotional learning
uh the sciences uh the humanities we're
doing things like test prep for the sat
for the lsat and we want to explore ways
to work
deeper with districts give them things
like district dashboards run efficacy
studies
uh and you know each of these things you
can double click on and have a bunch of
things that you have to figure out to do
right all while
tens of millions of folks are using the
platform uh uh
you know it can get complex sometimes so
i think navigating that complexity
but with that said you know no one
should feel sorry for me i i consider
myself
incredibly lucky to work with this team
to work with all of
the community at khan academy to work
with the hundreds of thousands of folks
who've donated to khan academy
uh to be able to work on you know what i
what i think is
uh kind of the central issue it's a
issue of education you know even some of
the issues that we're dealing with in
the world right now
especially in the us right now you know
i talked at length about it on monday
you know education can empower those who
are oppressed
and it can enlighten those who are
oppressors
because i do think that most people in
the world
are good or can be good but they've you
know might have had weird thoughts or
programming or experiences that maybe
uh maybe make them deviate from from
what would otherwise be their their good
selves and i think education is the way
to really
unlock and enlighten people and to see
the humanity in others
and to give everyone the critical
thinking so that they can
help navigate their own lives in a
positive way but also participate in a
democracy and
and you know democracy isn't just a
magical thing that's always going to
lead to good in order for democracy
to work the people voting and the people
that they're voting in
need to have be educated have really
strong critical thinking skills
be able to see issues from multiple
dimensions be able to empathize with
folks who are not like themselves
and and so you know it's a long term
it's a marathon it doesn't fix
everything overnight but if in the long
term if khan academy is able to reach
billions of folks and really empower
them
i think we can uh you know we can make
our positive dent in the universe so to
speak
let's see so tina liu says how many
books do you read every year
um you know i'm not i'm yeah i'm not
like uh you know
there's famous people like bill gates
who are known to you know kind of speed
read
consume books that is voracious i i i'm
first of all i'm not that fast of a
reader
uh and you know i'll say that just so
other non-fast readers feel
comfortable with saying that they're not
fast i have very good comprehension
but maybe that's a byproduct because i
actually don't read i'm probably the
slowest read you know my wife reads
faster than me my mother-in-law reads
faster than me probably many of y'all
read faster than me but i definitely
uh immerse myself when i'm in a book
when i'm in a book i definitely like
i'm in it like you know i'm in that
reality and that's probably why i i read
a little bit slower
uh but you know depends i probably read
a handful of books
a month maybe you know right now i'm
reading shantaram
which is a 900 page book and you know
i'm reading maybe you know 30 30 minutes
a night so
that's taking me more than a couple of
weeks to get through but i'm really
enjoying it
um but sometimes there's quite yes i
would have probably
probably about two or three books a
month
it sounds it sounds about right
sometimes it's less maybe one sometimes
it's at the high end of that but
that's about what i do um
so let's see we have a question
from john cheryl from
facebook any suggestions to get a 13
year old boy
hooked on reading i have ideas i'm not a
i'm not
the expert here but i could even try to
channel my own
13 year old self because i
and you know it even goes to the last
question i actually was not a strong
reader when i was in elementary school
uh when i was in second grade up until
second grade i was actually in speech
therapy
because i couldn't even communicate
properly i might it was funny my sister
was in
the gifted and talented program where
they took her out of class she was three
years older than me
and when they started taking me out of
class i assumed that
surely i'm ferrous brother i must be in
this program as well now it turns out
that no one could understand what i was
saying
so i remember going to these rooms
where they would just play these tapes
and make me repeat what they were saying
and you know people still didn't
understand
uh what i was saying and and so that
communic i i had gaps in communication i
couldn't
i wasn't that strong of a reader i
actually probably didn't really read
a full you know proper book until i was
near late elementary school or
or even in middle school so i you know
no one who knew me when i was eight or
nine years old
would have thought that i would have
become a voracious reader one day or
maybe probably been surprised that i
would have even gotten into education
um but in middle school you know i think
you know there's
there's a lot of great books that you're
exposed to in middle school uh
but they do tend to or i don't know i'm
sure things have changed a bit now but
when i was in middle school
they did tend to you know be a little
bit more of the victorian era classics
which now as an adult i really
appreciate i mean i said one of my
favorite books is jane austen's pride
and prejudice
but i think for middle school boys
especially
some of the great science fiction works
you know not to stereotype or generalize
because i think a lot of
girls young girls like to read these as
well but you know when i first read
uh the foundation series and i read that
in middle school
when i first read some of the arthur c
clarke
i read dune in high school you know i
always appreciated the victorian era
like the way to observe the nuances of
society
and and all that but also to have this
other dimension of like space
opera and like how epic the universe
could be and our roles
in it and to just think about reality in
different ways
i think that just gives you another
dimension so my advice a long-winded way
of saying
expose your son to more types of books
and see what
what he resonates with and sometimes you
know there's this gravity to
doing the very high-minded academic
classic stuff but i think there's just a
beauty in just getting started reading
and once you start immersing yourself in
books and you realize that it's the best
form of virtual reality and probably the
cheapest form of virtual reality
uh then then i think you you can get
your your son hooked and then he'll
start exploring things that might be a
little bit
um out of his his normal comfort zone uh
so that's my my my best guess
let's see there's a
nikhil govinder do i enjoy computer
sciences so what's my favorite
programming language
well i do i mean i was a computer
science major in college and the reason
why i did that it was you know this was
before it was obvious that computer
science was a very pragmatic field to go
into
it was because you know i originally
went into college wanting to be a
physics major because i wanted to
understand reality
and i still do but what was
captivating about computer science is
that it's kind of a world where you can
create a reality
and you can create tools that uh can
scale
arbitrarily to millions and millions of
folks uh and so
that's what got me into computer science
and obviously to some degree helped me
get khan academy going and kind of those
early prototypes of our of our platform
i don't i don't i don't say i have a
favorite programming language i always
view the programming languages as a
means to an
end you know it's not like i have a deep
love for python over
java over you know c plus plus or
whatever else
for me it's it's a mean to an end which
language is a better tool
for what i'm trying to accomplish uh at
that i've i've
always programmed more for the sake of
trying to create something that could be
useful or interesting versus
kind of just the programming for for
programming sake but i could definitely
see how people are
attracted to the beauty of the
programming itself because there is
something very beautiful
about kind of the logical structures uh
and i think it does really help you
learn to think critically
and logically regardless of whether you
end up becoming a programmer or not
let's see from youtube kevin braza says
hi sal
where would you say your optimism come
from i've always
admired that presence in your live
streams and videos also my background is
middle school science i would love to
help
uh well kevin thanks thanks that you see
that optimism
i mean look i i think you know we all
have a choice in life
things are going to happen to us for
sure um
and you know and i consider myself lucky
that when you look at the whole spectrum
of the things that can happen to you in
life
i for the most part avoided most of the
really bad ones and you know knock on
wood
uh but no matter what happens to you a
lot depends on how you
choose to look at it you know and
there's the same you know cliches glass
half full of glass half empty
and i have found that no matter what
life throws at
you or at least it goes in me if i take
it from a kind of a more optimistic
point of view
it's more productive it's more
constructive it puts positive energy
out there you know i've said it multiple
times on this live stream
for students going to college and saying
i'm you know i need to go to this
college or that college or i need to go
into that career
i was like it's really what you put out
there that comes back regardless of
where you go to college or what you work
in if you put positive energy out there
if you have a sense of curiosity if you
genuinely care about other people
then they will generally care about you
things will be interesting you will get
a lot of the out of the experience so i
think when you when you're that clicks
they're like wow i should be optimistic
and you know i'm sure you know who knows
i don't know how much of this is
hardwired
into folks i would say in high school
you know in certain circles i was
probably optimistic in certain
places i was probably a little bit angry
i was probably a little bit angsty i
said in the past i was the
lead singer of a heavy metal band and
you know if i were to see some of the
lyrics that we
we had it probably would make in fact it
would make me cringe today
uh because we were you know i was angry
i was frustrated for you know who knows
how much of it was you know teenage
angst how much was it just context that
i was in
um uh but you know when i reflect on
that
i realize it's much more it's much
better to be uh
not not as not as angsty it's a better
way it's a better way to approach the
world and the world
kind of tends to reflect that back uh
when when you do it you know what one
piece of advice and i do this to myself
all the time
is for smiles you know for smile you
might say like that seems forced like
literally
like smile uh but i actually have read
research that you know just as if you're
happy
it makes you naturally smile it's almost
hard not to smile if you're happy
the other way around if you force a
smile
that looks a little bit sinister uh that
it can it can actually make make you a
little bit
make you a little bit happier it's it's
you know so i try it out everyone who's
watching try to try to force a smile i
know there's a lot going on in the world
right now that's stressful and
should should not make any of us happy
uh but
uh you know you it's it it doesn't it
doesn't help you or the world to
you know be be down uh we should always
be kind of
like hey you know look this is the this
is the data these are the
this is what we have to deal with now
what how can we put one foot in front of
the other to make
positive change i think is always the
question we should we should be asking
ourselves and we have this one life to
live
and so as we try to make that positive
change even when we fail even when we
get knocked down
how do we live in the moment and
appreciate these moments we have to
even sometimes fail uh and and and and
make the
most of it so
let's see elliot h says dumbledore sal
well thank you for calling that as
as many of you all know i've always had
the secret aspiration to be a
dumbledore-like figure one day um did
you always have a
buddhist flash hindi hindu detached
philosophy when did you start forcing
yourself to smile and enjoy the process
rather than frown worrying about the
result
um you know it's interesting i mean a
lot of these ideas are often
associated with eastern philosophies
like buddhists or hindu you know vedic
philosophies
but if you look at um almost any
philosophical system
even many from the west stoicism
famously you know from
from the greeks and the romans it's
essentially the same
general idea of not becoming attached to
the
outcome and really just doing what is
right
not only will you be a in some ways a
better human being
but you're also going to be a happier
human being a more peaceful human being
and if you look at some of the
especially the mystical traditions in
you know some of the the major religions
um
you know you look at some sufi
traditions you look at gnosticism and
christianity
um there's definitely the mystical
traditions in judaism
they they also uh kind of go into some
of these
these same ideas you know in hebrew the
word sin
uh we we have this notion that sin is
you know when you go against the laws of
you know the divine laws or however you
want to divide define it but
the original meaning of sin is to miss
the point
and uh you know there are
interpretations of many religions where
you know
notions of evil are much more about
getting sucked in to
into the illusion of
power and materiality and
you know comparing yourself to others
and
you know status uh and that that almost
constructs
you know not to get too philosophical
but that almost constructs a hell of it
of its own sort in your mind because
that obsession that anxiety
over you know keeping up with others
comparing to others i'm not where i
should be
i want to be richer i want to be more
powerful i want to be better looking i
want to have better things
that almost that that missing the point
almost creates a form of of uh
of a hell even in your own mind so i
think this is actually a thread that
that
exists throughout uh pretty much any uh
any religious tradition or any
philosophical system like like the
stoics
uh but you know i i think i i kind of uh
personally you know stumbled into this
i've always been intrigued by
making sense of the universe that we
live in uh and i think
you know i think it was really when
you're a teenager that you really
you know a lot of teenagers out there
think that okay you know people who are
50 60 70 or 80 years old must be way
deeper than i am because they've had so
much more time to think about it
but i think it's actually middle
schoolers and teenagers that are the
ones that are oftentimes
the thinking the most deeply about some
of these like why do we exist
why am i here what's the purpose of life
and then when often happens you go to
college you get a job you have a family
and you're just like okay i gotta pay my
mortgage
i gotta make sure my kids learn how to
swim i gotta
you know i have all these social
gatherings i gotta make sure that you
know i get that promotion and so
actually i think a lot of adults
have almost that that muscle of thinking
deeply about the universe we live in
and what it what it means to be a good
person etc etc
oftentimes atrophies um so
uh anyway to answer your question
probably in in middle school i was drawn
to
some of these things and i continue to
be and i think now that i'm
middle aged um you know and i realized
that
you know that the time goes by very very
very fast in life uh you know it feels
like
just yesterday i was in college but
that's literally 20 years ago
and you know another 20 years i'm going
to be in well into my 60s another 20
years of that if i'm lucky
you know i i may or may not be around
uh and so i think it is that you know
you can't you can't i i
a lot of times people think it's a
distraction to think about these
philosophical ideas or our purpose in
life or
you know how we fit into the cosmos or
you know the nature of
however you want to view it god the
universe but i don't think
it's ever too early to think about that
if anything you know a lot of the other
things we
we have in our life is a distraction
from that you know there's i forgot who
said it i forgot which
philosophical system it came out of but
you know when you meditate and you still
your mind
it's much more about it's not about
forgetting your
kind of problems it's more about
remembering what you really are that you
aren't defined just by
your name your persona your gender
your status in the world your education
all of these things that you know
frankly
our egos identify very strongly with but
when you when you really fill your mind
you realize that you're an awareness
and that's all you really know and and
and
and that when you kind of strip away
some of those other things it can give
you it can give you peace and
clarity on a lot of levels that um you
know not just kind of a spiritual level
but but to engage with the world
as a whole but anyway i'll get off of my
soapbox
uh on on philosophy
um john corley from facebook says you
are aging sal just like me
silver fox unlike me yes
i guess i am i have to say you know all
this all this high-minded talk about
you know not being um not having vanity
and not having not been connected you
know not letting your ego run
there is something that hit me when i
hit 40. i'm now 43 gonna hit you know
b44
uh where it was it it it it it didn't
hit my wife as bad
it hit me and maybe that's maybe i do
have more vanity than i'd like to admit
uh but it was that realization you know
that i'm i'm you know
my wife and i've been married 16 years
and when we got married you know we were
in their 20s we're you know
we're young 16 years kind of went by
super fast i think that's a reflection
of my
wife being a very obama being a
wonderful person to share a life with
but i'm like wait another 16 years i'm
going to be 60. 60 is
like i never imagined myself being 60
and and so yeah no there there is
something about about aging that that
definitely starts to hit you at least
hit me when i'm 40 and
um and uh yeah but we're all aging
you know the beard isn't isn't helping
because my beard is is grayer than
normal but you know i
i'm resisting any temptations to to to
to use any uh
dyes or anything to to try to be
something that i'm not but i'm sure
those words will come to bite me back
when i show up on this live stream with
you know
jet black beard in a few weeks
um let's see we have maybe a time for it
for uh
one or two more questions um
let's see see
how it let's see there's a lot of see
atara lepets asked from facebook how
would i maintain mastery-based learning
in university
you know what i would say when you're
learning things in university don't just
cram for the test yes try to get good
grades and if you need a cram sometimes
because you kind of let things fly a
little bit
do that but always review it and learn
and try to learn from mastery and if you
do that what you're going to find is
if you really master those introductory
courses in college
the rest of the courses actually end up
pretty intuitive if you don't master
those introductory courses in college
the rest of the courses in college are
going to continue to be a struggle and
you're going to continue you have to
cram and
you feel like you're not really learning
anything so i would say especially those
that introductory courses get really
deep mastery of them
and then you'll be pretty unstoppable i
mean i know people with phds in biology
and they're you know it's and and if
they and they'll tell you
they really if you really master that
first year biology course
you can you can have a very deep
conversation with with them or with your
professors or
whoever else that's my best uh advice
um let me one more question tina lou do
you like teaching um
yeah i mean if it's not obvious i love
it uh you know i consider myself very
fortunate because
you know to be able to in you know to be
able to have the opportunity to learn
material
in a non-stressful way where i'm not
being evaluated but i can just
learn it for the sake of learning but
then have a reason for learning it so
that i can
digest it in my own mind and then help
other people get to the same place i
think
it's a incredibly powerful thing and i
remember when i was a kid
reading textbooks from you know
some you know great thinkers so to speak
there's a certain connection that you
form across time and space when you're
able to go really deep in especially
intellectual or philosophical subjects
and you know i i feel very privileged
and very lucky that
uh hopefully you know i can help and the
khan academy team can help
form those same connections with people
that we might not know across time and
space you know there might be some
young girl in the village some place in
300 years and hopefully khan academy's
still around
and maybe some of our existing content
is con hopefully still useful for her
and she's just like oh wow i feel
connection with these folks
uh back in you know the the 21st century
uh i think there's just something really
cool about that and you know as
i was just saying you know we're in this
puzzle
called life and to understand it and
learning new things
is the best way i can think of of really
trying to make sense of
of this puzzle we're in this universe
we're in um
and our purpose in you know the fairly
limited time that we have
so i'll let everyone go i i got a little
bit more philosophical maybe uh
maybe the what the what's going on in
the world is making maybe maybe all of
us a little bit more philosophical now
um i hope you know i i like i pride
myself that khan academy where
you know we're non-political we
definitely you know i i try to keep
you know any kind of clear religious or
spiritual beliefs to myself because
uh we're not you know we're not about
condoning one one side or anything a
one one one spiritual view or another so
i hope i didn't cross any lines
uh but i just uh i want to thank
everyone for joining and as always i
enjoy this and you know this these
these really stressful times obviously
uh you have everything going on
uh in the us which is um
you know the the the i was i i was i'm
trying to pick between the words
fortunate or unfortunate it's good that
finally it feels like there's energy
behind making change obviously
the unfortunate thing is the context
that are
forcing folks to have to to take a lot
of action here
but you know between that um and
obviously what's going on covet 19 and
being socially distant i know it's a
hard time for a lot a lot of folks
so just encourage you yourself you know
don't don't take it easy on yourself
no matter what life stage you are in um
and try to enjoy the moment give
yourself some moments of stillness
try to force a smile every now and then
and hopefully those smiles become a
little bit more automatic and adorable
and i will see all of y'all on monday
you